hello to you smart thank you for joining
us on the program this morning broken
rotten institutionally racist
misogynistic and homophobic
how did you sleep last night
this is a very very worrying report I
returned to policing after a few years
out last September recognizing the
challenges we face and I'm resolved that
we will reform policing and I know the
vast majority of my people are this is a
very upsetting read you can't read this
report and not be upset embarrassed and
humbled by some of what's been said the
one thing that's heartening in it for me
the evidence in this report comes from
the men and women in my organization who
care deeply who want us to do better who
want us to be different and it's with my
resolve and their resolve that we will
reform the culture of the met and we
will do better for the people of London
do you accept the full findings of the
report
we accept the findings of the report as
I say it's a it's deeply worrying
do you accept a full
we accept the or accept the findings of
the reports absolutely
the full findings of the report
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand that
you know exactly what I mean we're
talking about your suggestions that you
don't accept
um that your force is institutionally
racist
I absolutely accept the diagnosis that
Louise Casey comes up with we have
racist misogynists and homophobes in the
organization and it's not just about
individuals we have systemic failings
management failings and cultural
failings the reason and I respect Louise
using that term the reason I don't use
it um I think it's a very ambiguous term
your your viewers would have different
interpretations what it means
to Mark so Mark if I may I purposefully
looked it up in the dictionary this
morning institutionally means uh
convention or Norm in a culture and
that's what Louise Casey thinks is
happening in the met you tell me why
it's not
so that you've proven my point I'm sorry
to say because
um the definition you pulled out is not
the one that William McPherson used it's
not the one that Louise Casey uses
everyone uses different definitions it's
pointless arguing about definitions we
have a real problem here we have
misogyny homophobia and racism in the
organization and we're going to root it
out I've already grown our capability to
do that we're absolutely determined to
take this on we're removing officers
more quickly we're tackling these issues
and meanwhile day in the day out I've
got the office of the force who are
coming forward and they are absolutely
determined to tackle this the vast
majority are as embarrassed and angered
by this as I am and we want to make a
difference okay well that was certainly
the phrase that we used was used in an
English dictionary if you want to take
um
I'm not sure whether you do or not but
there we go baroness Casey pin the
primary uh blame on past leadership you
were previously assistant commissioner
and held very senior roles at the Met
between
2011 and 2018 what responsibility do you
accept
I think all of us who've LED in policing
need to reflect on why we didn't see the
scale of this earlier and I certainly
I'm certainly doing that as I say I've
had four years out of policing and I've
come back because I'm absolutely
determined that we need to tackle this I
think you'll find up in more outspoken
on the need for police reform over the
last six months than
um probably any police leader for
decades so we are already put it in
place a turnaround plan we're making big
strides already luis's recommendations
will massively influence uh thinking and
the plans we have ahead to reform for
policing for London as we strengthen our
work in neighborhoods as we improve the
response to victims and as we tackle the
toxic individuals in the organization
need to removing
so you
are to go to tackle these issues and
I've been absolutely clear that that's
what's required and I think Louise Casey
has has backed the fact that we're up
for this well no she hasn't she said
that she puts the primary blame at past
leadership and that's you
she's also spoken about the changing
tone that the new leadership has brought
in the organization we're absolutely
determined to deliver the transformation
required that's what I returned policing
for and that's what we're doing as I say
we're building neighborhood policing
we're strengthening our response to
victims and we're rooting out these
individuals who've undermined us so so
badly we're sacking officers at a
greater race and we're and the
information is coming from our own staff
who want this to change okay we only
have a limited amount of time 34 000
police officers how confident can you be
that among those ranks there aren't
others this morning that are capable of
rape and murder of innocent young women
on the Streets of London
we are systematically going through
please answer my questions if you would
how confident can you be that you don't
have other rapists in your ranks
I'm doing everything possible to to
identify if there's any risk of that
whatsoever we're reveetting all of our
officers reviewing all the old cases of
allegations against officers I'm doing
everything possible to remove to spot
anybody and remove them who proposes any
risk to the public
are there still officers working for you
this morning that are guilty of domestic
abuse and indecent exposure
and there's one reported in the um daily
mail recently who's guilty of a decent
exposure that's why we that's why we're
reviewing all of our cases we're
bringing a new vetting method to um to
remove officers who fail vetting I've
been asking the Home Secretary and the
Prime Minister for new powers to improve
police regulations to make it easier to
deal with these issues we are absolutely
determined to tackle the toxic
individuals who remain in this
organization shouldn't be here there's
no doubt about that whatsoever so you
acknowledge to Mark there are others
that could very well be others
there are toxic individuals in this
organization who are in the process of
removing now
okay who could be responsible for a
domestic abuse indecent exposure perhaps
even rape
I'm not going to get into if split some
babies we've got toxic individuals some
of whom have been who've got
concerns about their
predatory behavior we've got people
suspended we've got people under
investigation we are roots in the mouth
of this organization
are committed by the end of March to
give an update on the work we've been
doing on this and I'll publish that then
okay so you can give us an idea at this
stage of how many you're looking at
I'm gonna I'm gonna give a full update
on that at the end of March we're
working through this work systematically
an easier one I mean will you just stand
the Parliamentary and diplomatic
protection unit as suggested by the
report uh cousins and Carrick both
members of that
so um the report says we should
effectively disband it we're going to do
everything possible to reform and change
um
as much as possible
um I have to protect Parliament tomorrow
I have to protect embassies tomorrow I
can't just take all those offices away
and and stop doing that we're going to
do everything possible to change the
culture in that in in that department
and with the Vigor and um and radicalism
that Louise case is calling for so not
following the recommendations of the
report then
we're absolutely following the
recommendations and we've discussed this
with noise
she says effectively displan this so
you're not quoting the report correctly
she's effectively spanned it we're gonna
and she wants us to be as radical as we
possibly can do in changing it she
absolutely said I've had this
conversation with her face to face she
absolutely understands that we can't
break it up overnight and still protect
Parliament but she wants us to be as
radical as we can be in changing the
culture and changing the people in there
we've already brought in new leadership
uh as a senior level half the sergeants
are different we're looking to we're
bringing in lots of new recruits into it
to change the culture there's a lot
going on there and we're going to
reflect on those recommendations see
what more we can do yeah um reflect on
them okay uh not necessarily adopt them
um as met Police Commissioner you have
to rely on the that's asleep
on policing nine million londoners by
consent the report says that that
pillion principle is at risk
if that is the case how can londoners
feel safe with you in charge this
morning
so I have a thousands tens of thousands
of officers going out day after day
they're out there today protecting
londoners they're arresting dangerous
people they're protecting the vulnerable
and they're doing a fantastic job this
report is deeply worrying and you're
right um fixing my consent in London has
been damaged by recent events trust has
declined over the last four years that's
what we're here to do to turn that round
londoners can have absolute confidence
that we're here to turn that round and
improve the service that they get we
stay right this is Earth
how can they be when you say you don't
know whether you've got rapists
murderers people that abuse women within
your ranks and you can't even talk in
more detail about that this morning we
have to wait for yet another report
I said I'm absolutely clear we're doing
everything we possibly can do to look
back because those cases those four
cases of cousins and
so those awful cases of cousins and
Carrick what they show is that our
systems have not been strong enough at
spotting toxic individuals dangerous
individuals within our ranks and for
that reason we've taken everyone's
details in the organization and we work
with you reviewing them against all the
National Police databases
the mark That's you you were there at
the force for years that's you you're
the past leadership you have to accept
responsibility for this and fall on your
sword
um we have we have gone through all the
details of all of our officers and
reviewing them against National Police
databases we're looking at past
allegations to make sure they haven't
been badly investigated and we haven't
made mistakes and the people who
shouldn't be here we're working through
it systematically so londoners can be
happy that we look for every possible
risk in the organization remove those
individuals we're removing organizations
are going to be very happy with you this
morning sir
well I hope they see that we're
absolutely resolved and we're determined
to take these issues on the identified
in this report
Ron let's see what he has to say for now
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on the program I know a difficult day
ahead thank you very much and thank you